what was this Max Kaiser offered Alex
Jones 10,000 Bitcoins last week or
whatever did you see the TW the Twitter
of him going we're not selling he's like
screaming on they're not selling wait
wait wait he so the story is Max offered
Alex Jones 10,000 Bitcoins 300 something
million dollars by today's standard and
Alex like didn't care and like lost it
or something said whatever and then Max
told him I'll give you another 10,000 if
you can answer five Bitcoin questions
and Alex couldn't do it and apparently
they were like not complicated questions
but they're questions like basically if
you're in Bitcoin you knew right and uh
he offered him $300 million well that's
not even enough to cover half of his
fines unfortunately you no a third yeah
that's the funny thing like if he
actually gave him the crypto it' be gone
in two seconds sees it by the way I did
a show with Chase Geer this morning I
love Chase Infowars that's what made me
think about it early this morning check
it out um also when you're wondering is
crypto going to go up you also got to
ask yourself is the US dollar going to
go down